Ils voulaient son visage bas, le cul haut, ses mains menottées, ses chevilles lacées.
Ils la voulaient consciente qu'elle ne pourrait les désirer.
Oh, ils la voulaient sacrée,
baptisée dans sa divinité,
ils voulaient ses secrets,
des perles pour les pourceaux.
Ils voulaient résoudre le mystère de sa forme.
Fascinés par la gloire, hypnotisés par son style.
Oh, ils la voulaient complète.
Ils la voulaient entière,
mais ils vinrent fractionnés, peu enthousiastes, peu éclairés,
sans estime ni connaissance de qui elle était en réalité.
Oh, mais s'ils savaient.
S'ils la connaissaient,
des chants de prière pleuvraient des nuages de leurs yeux,
clarifiant la vision, baignant le cœur.
Ils s'inclineraient à chaque fois qu'ils la verraient.
Seraient leurs meilleurs eux-mêmes en sa présence.
S'ils la connaissaient,
savaient qu'elle était la colle de leur révolution,
l'écoulement vital de sang à travers leurs veines.
S'ils la connaissaient,
elle saurait,
elle sentirait,
que son corps est plus qu'un champ de bataille.
Plus qu'une fracture osseuse et qu'un sectarisme saignant.
Plus qu'un pont au-dessus de votre conscience perturbée.
Plus qu'épuisée, piétinée, transpercée, fusillée.
Plus que votre « Selma, Lord, Selma » Edmund Pettus.
Plus que votre tueuse Katrina Danziger.
Plus que votre échappatoire de Baltimore « l'autoroute pour nulle part ».
S'ils la connaissaient,
elle saurait.
(Chant)
Les femmes sauvages,
les femmes sauvages, elles marchent avec les bisons.
Ont la foudre sur leur langue,
font voler des fouets comme armes.
Les femmes sauvages, elles marchent avec des machettes.
Avec sagesse, avec grâce, avec aisance.
Les femmes sauvages ont des ouragans dans leur ventre,
libérant un déluge de leçons.
Oh, les femmes sauvages, elles volent librement.
Observez juste leurs manières, comment elles déchirent et détruisent.
Oh, qui peut la comprendre,
ce fleuve Niger sinueux qu'est cette femme,
une qui n'a pas peur de partir
pour seulement vagabonder puis devenir le vent.
Elle qui parle en rafales et en cyclones,
nous repoussant vers un terrain élevé, une conscience élevée,
elle tourne et le monde également.
Sentez-la tourner,
couvrir plusieurs durées de vie.
Entendez-la parler, une alarme qui sonne.
Voyez-la danser, invoquant les morts,
ressuscitant une nouvelle vie.
Le paradis l'entend toquer à la porte,
qui transporte prudemment ceux qui appellent son aide.
Les femmes sauvages, elles ouvrent des portails vers de nouveaux mondes,
de nouveaux discours, de nouveaux rêves.
Oh, mes très chers,
si défunts des manières du gardien,
prenez garde.
Les femmes sauvages ne sont pas à domestiquer.
Seulement à admirer.
Laissez-la juste entrer, et observez-la mettre vos jours en flammes.
(Acclamations) (Applaudissements)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)